hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
um april 18th
i guess it's tax day
according to my phone
hey man your taxes
are due man i thought they were doing
the 15th when i was growing up when i
was just a lad
when it was [ __ ]
you know what do i remember 68 cents per
gallon 75 cents per gallon
april 15th
the old federal reserve came around
knocking at the door
to see what the hell you were up with so
happy tax day
um i hope you're getting your
interest-free loan
back from um the powers that be rather
than owing any money
um
you know it's funny a friend of mine
reached out to me
oh he reached out to me hey you know
what's going on i haven't talked to you
in a while blah blah blah he goes i
ended up in texas of all places and i
said dallas and he said yes and i was
like i love dallas
so i was like let me look at real estate
in dallas
let me let me play out this fantasy
where i get the [ __ ] out of here
you know what i'm getting the [ __ ] out
of here i love that i'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here where you going
i'm going to a different state
the [ __ ]
people over there when you borrow a cup
of sugar whatever the [ __ ] it is you do
nowadays with your neighbors
they're way better people man to hang
out with i got to be honest with you if
you have to leave a whole [ __ ] state
doesn't it at some point you gotta look
in the mirror and be like what's going
on with me
you can't deal with anybody in this
state i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
dude you living here nah dude
where'd you go dude three years ago i
was like i'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here
i was like [ __ ] this place
how many times i've said that in my life
from states to bars
to schools
you know and you can't just leave you
can't just leave somewhere you always
have to say [ __ ] that place when you're
leaving it
hey
you ever been to magic mountain
nah man [ __ ] that place
yeah really you never went nah i went i
thought you said you didn't go
no i did go i don't i didn't like the
way i was treated so i was just like you
know i went there and
you know
i was playing the [ __ ] shoot the
water pistol into the [ __ ] clown's
mouth
and the guy [ __ ] the timer on me so i
didn't win the big big teddy bear [ __ ]
that place
and you're right i'm going to see if
there's an actual page of that the
number one [ __ ] that place
in america
there has to be
dude [ __ ] that place
you bend it up dude [ __ ] that plate hang
on a second
number one
[ __ ] that place
place
all right
[ __ ] that place official [ __ ] this place
official video
from gwar
it's an actual song
these these are musicians they took time
to write a piece of music that said [ __ ]
this place [ __ ] this place from the
blood of god's album
the story of gwar is carved across i
gotta find out what place they're
talking about
[ __ ] this place transition translation
into spanish
it's gotta be puta
somewhere in there you gotta tag it with
that right
um song by frightened rabbit [ __ ] this
place
all right
then it goes into limp biscuit see a lot
of
a
anger
of anger with [ __ ] this place speaking
of that [ __ ] speaking of [ __ ]
anger boston celtics fans still upset
with kyrie irving now granted granted
the guy stomped on the [ __ ]
celtics uh you know logo
last year when they beat us in the
playoffs i guess so whatever the [ __ ]
happened i don't know what
so all i know
is i'm riding around with my lovely
bride
well we had like a big easter weekend i
got to talk about the easter bunny right
i got to talk about that [ __ ] at some
point remind me remind me to talk about
the easter bunny anyway so i'm riding
around my lovely bride
and um
ended up you know
i had to meet up with somebody because i
had to practice something that i have to
do this week that has a little there's a
little bit of pressure involved right
so
i got that out of the way i'm like where
do you want to go she's like i don't
know how about we go buy a cigar bar
right hang out for a second we go
walking in lo and behold the celtics
game is on in the second half
i knew it was on today i just didn't
know when
and um
i was like oh my god this is perfect and
they got the [ __ ] celtics game on
this is great so i sat down i watched
like mid third quarter on it just killed
me the celtics fans were chanting
uh kyrie sucks
the guy doesn't suck
and why are you pissing off
the star of the other team how many of
these [ __ ] jordan documentaries do
they have to make you guys you don't
understand i'm not just talking about
celtics fans fans in general just do not
understand because they think
that superstar athletes are wired the
same way they are
you know
there's a reason you're sitting in the
stands
because when you played ball and
somebody told you you sucked
you put your head down you swung at the
first three pitches and went back to the
bench am i talking about me right now um
that's how you think that's not how they
think
they think oh you think i suck
great
fantastic you know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna drop [ __ ] 40
and [ __ ] watch you drive out of here
drying the tears off your son's face
that's that's all that does that doesn't
rattle a star player you get some
[ __ ] bum coming off the bench
but usually they go in during garbage
time anyway you don't heckle the star
of another team kyrie hadn't what do you
have [ __ ] 39 40 41 whatever the [ __ ]
he had you knew that was coming but the
celtics
pull it out
the incredible it did not look like a
good play i don't know any of the guys
names collapsed in the corner all of a
sudden it crossed the court what the
[ __ ] are we doing
and
over to jason tatum
little twister roo whatever the [ __ ] you
saying basketball
up for the win
at the [ __ ] buzzer incredible place
goes nuts
uh but it's going to be a long series
celtics fans stop chanting kyrie sucks i
want to win this series okay
i get it he stepped on the [ __ ] logo
oh
what are we gonna gang
did he disrespect us who gives a [ __ ] we
got 17 banners
you know hanging above his head who
gives a [ __ ] let's just beat him that's
what i want to do
i want us to beat the brooklyn nets
um
by the way
um
what's his face uh
durant i like durant
he looks like a [ __ ] like i don't
know what his what his deal is man he
just he he doesn't look like he's from
this time
you know
he's got like that that greg odom
disease where he just looked like he was
40 when he was [ __ ] 25
you know that's what a big man used to
look like
as far into his career as he is
back in the day
they come out there and they look like
somebody's dad and they had a look on
your their face like you didn't want to
[ __ ] with them now everybody still looks
like a kid
i don't maybe because i'm old as [ __ ]
that's probably part of it but
i don't know i actually like
a lot of the uh brooklyn nets but anyway
celtics fans don't chant kyrie sucks
all right just let him go out there and
[ __ ] do whatever the [ __ ] he's gonna
do
i swear to god telling him that he sucks
is gonna add seven points to his [ __ ]
final stats i'm telling you
he doesn't suck you know he doesn't suck
you know as a celtics fan i wish he
tried
a little more he's one of those guys he
needs to get motivated so he's got to go
to a city make everybody hate him and
then he [ __ ] tries against him when
he goes to the next team or whatever but
if you're going to chant something i was
tweeting about that you're going to
chant something about kyrie chant
something to take him out of the game
like chant the world is round
that's a hard one the world is round
the earth is round still one syllable
you figure it out
right
and then you have him thinking about
you know how he can prove to you that
you're looking down at a cereal bowl not
at a ball
you want him thinking about that [ __ ]
topography
geography paleontology you want him
thinking about that [ __ ] you don't just
say that he sucks because then he's
gonna [ __ ] drop 40 on you
now if you're a gambler
all right
and you go to the celtics game
and you got money on the nets even
though your hats with the celtics
then by all means
you heckle kyrie that's actually a
[ __ ] move
right
you you actually go on the road
and you have you heckle the stars of
your own team
and they'll think that you're fans of
the hometown team they'll try extra hard
they'll cover the spread you win money
and your home team wins how about that
in theory
in theory that worked in my head
figured all that out and it just [ __ ]
worked
um
anyway had a big uh
big dad mom weekend it was easter
weekend and um
my daughter's hilarious we went over to
this church
and they had this easter egg hunt and it
was awesome you know
it's all the guys on the mic you know
one of those guys that's involved in the
neighborhood
but you know can put a few away you know
guys guy right he's on the mic we all do
the bunny hop
hopping across the parking lot
son and daughter everybody's having a
great time the kids are having a great
time beautiful day
everything's awesome and um
you know the easter bunny's there and
stuff
definitely looking like it was on a
plant-based diet you know i know santa
claus is supposed to be fat is the
easter bunny supposed to be a little fat
too this one looked a little a little
skinny right so anyway
we do the easter egg hunt and all of
that type of [ __ ]
everybody's having a good time there's
always a couple of psycho parents like
like coaching their kids on how to get
the most eggs
you're just like oh god what are you a
banker who gives a [ __ ]
[Music]
talking to your kid like it's the
beginning of survivor
um
yeah i saw someone doing that
everybody's gonna stop but you go deep
you go deep into the into the field
that's where all the eggs are the kids
sitting there like [ __ ]
talking like a three-year-old
five-year-old or something it's
hilarious
anyway
so we have a great time 99.9 everybody
over there was [ __ ] great
and um
so we ended up going home
and my daughter says to me
you know i asked her she had fun and she
was like yeah
yeah i go i go that's great i'm glad you
had a good time she goes yeah but that
wasn't the real easter bunny
and i'm like
i'm like
and i just looked at her and she goes
you know i knew and i set out and she
said he was wearing shoes
[Music]
she goes easter bunny doesn't wear shoes
so me and my wife are like crying
laughing not trying to like give the
whole thing away
and then i went back and looked at the
video and the dude or the woman in the
the [ __ ] bunny suit
um
they had a white bunny suit on with like
black [ __ ] sneakers
like ref shoes like walking around and
every kid you know it's weird enough
that you know
you're looking at this thing that's
supposed to be a rabbit they already
know what a rabbit looks like and this
thing's you're walking around on two
[ __ ] legs
you know
then you're as skinny as flamingo legs
that doesn't help and then you're
walking around in ref shoes
it actually made me feel good
because um i know some kids get really
upset at the end of this [ __ ] when they
find out
you know just wait a minute wait a
minute i should have said something
before anybody's listening to this with
your kids if you listen with your kids
you're crazy
but if you are listening to this with
your kids just don't listen to the next
thing i'm gonna say when you tell them
that someone okay some of these things
are not real
all of these things
uh from the tooth fairy to the currency
that you put under under the pillow none
of it's [ __ ] real
um
the fact that you actually have somebody
walking around a bunny rabbit suit with
sneakers on you know i guess my
my daughter ever gives me [ __ ] about it
i'm just gonna say that to her
and just be like look you said when you
were five you knew it wasn't real
because it was wearing shoes
all right i don't know why it's just
something you do you like seeing your
kids get excited
and you just i don't know you just lie
about it i don't know why why do we do
that
what is the what is the reason for all
of this [ __ ] the [ __ ] tooth fairy and
all of this crap why make up all this
magical horseshit
you know what it was because when they
came up with it
back in the day i think parents didn't
have ipads
if they had ipads they wouldn't had to
[ __ ] make up all of this dumb [ __ ] to
to make your kid go to bed you know you
could just
hand him an ipad and have him do
whatever
um
oh you know what's a hard thing to do
is to be the cool guy not looking at his
phone and like
wanting to get recognition for it it's
really difficult because you're the cool
guy not looking at your phone and
everybody else is looking at their phone
so then you're sitting there it's like
the george costanza moment where he
wants to get credit for the big tip and
he didn't so he reaches back in to pull
it out again and they think he's
stealing
sort of like that is it like that i
don't know
um anyway
why am i yawning this much um
celtics up one game to none
against the formidable very formidable
uh
brooklyn nets so we'll see how this goes
but the celtics number two number two
ranked in the east i love it you know
and the [ __ ] lakers didn't make the
playoffs you know so i'm sure that
they're going to go out and go buy the
whole [ __ ] league again
so they can be like we have 18 [ __ ]
i saw somebody with a lakers hat and it
said 17 nba championships and i so like
it's so pathetic that i have to walk up
to and be like
okay let's look at that number here okay
it's 16 it's one nbl
and uh
four nba titles in minneapolis one nbl
title or whatever the [ __ ] it was called
uh bb
a whatever the [ __ ] it was called title
all right
you have 12 the los angeles lakers have
12. that's what you have everybody in la
padding their resume
um
but i am excited that lebron was saying
that he wants to go to golden
state that makes me very happy because
if he goes there they're just they're
going to win that's it
and then the lakers won't win which is
fantastic
so that's all i root for at this point
i know nobody real free agents want to
you know either what la can offer you
just can't you know the sunshine the
supermodels
you know
i mean if you're gonna deal with police
brutality
you you want the la weather
[Music]
um
so anyway i also watched
i watched my first full red sox game
on saturday and i watched most of today
when they've been wearing those um
the marathon
in honor of the victims of the boston
marathon
the yellow uniforms with the blue i
thought it was like ucla versus the red
sox because the twins you know they got
the navy with the red you know
um
i don't know at first i wasn't into him
and then by the end you know after two
games i was like i kind of like that hat
i could wear that out here on the west
coast people think it's a ucla hat
but not a red sox hat so then i wouldn't
have to worry about getting [ __ ]
stabbed in the kidney when i go to
trader joe's
so there you go
it's an incredible thing
um i like this red sox team you know i
love i also love uh
the pitcher that pitched today
michael walker i mean that's just the
perfect boston name walker and you're
not [ __ ] uh
you're not mispronouncing it it's w
something like w
a
or something like that
i'm not gonna lie to you it's a bad name
for a pitcher if you have a rough day
michael walk michael walker michael
walks the whole [ __ ] lineup dude
um garrett whitlock i was liking him
coming out of the bullpen
alex verdugo hitting three
i saw his the the third of i guess he's
had three monstrous home runs this year
i'm kind of liking it
deborah's a big uh
defensive play
i'm liking that we got a really good
[ __ ] team i hope we got some pictures
i haven't seen chris sales name anywhere
i don't know if he's coming out
um
if he's healthy or not we got rid of him
i have no idea what's going on with him
but um
i've been loving the uh
loving watching baseball though
i really like it i haven't uh done it in
a while i had i get the package every
year but last year why the [ __ ] was i so
busy i can't remember
i was doing something and i just missed
basically the whole season but i always
make the playoffs and this year i got in
early
um
and we shall see we got the blue jays
coming up
who were talking all of this [ __ ] right
last year was the trailer this year's
the movie we're going to see
um
with that one-man wrecking machine
vladimir guerrero jr jr jesus christ
over there
um i also watched some formula one can
you tell that i'm wrapped on the movie
i'm all getting all caught up
um
congratulations to charles leclerc
and the ferrari team
opening up an early lead on mercedes
they got 78 points charles leclerc does
uh let's look at the standings here well
well we got this whole thing going on
let's back it up here
that was it george russell second place
he's okay 71 points 37 points
uh
the other ferrari driver
33 points perez has 30 lewis hamilton 28
max verstappen 25
he's got one win one podium and then two
back to back
did not finishes
that's what's killing me the amount of
point not only the points he left the
points that he gave lewis hamilton
because you got to be thinking
that these mercedes this team is not
going to be like this for the whole
season it's going to be ferrari versus
mercedes for his [ __ ] red bull this
is like this is the season all of these
years i've been whining
that it's lewis hamilton's race to the
first turn and if he's there the whole
[ __ ] race is over and it's boring as
[ __ ]
two things they got way more parody now
and
espn whoever the [ __ ] doing the
coverage is doing a great job of
covering the racing in the middle of um
in the middle of the pack
when someone you know
like charles leclerc has like a four
five second lead and i'm just watching a
guy drive around the track it's great
now that they're showing the middle of
the race but they're probably showing
the middle of the race because lewis
hamilton's in seventh place now they're
paying attention back there you get to
see some racing over there
you know
um anyway
i'm all over the place here i i did a
million dad things and i'm trying to
watch enough [ __ ] here so i can get
caught up
with the [ __ ] world
um i'm assuming the ukraine is still uh
kicking some ass over there because i
haven't seen any stories about it
although i'm also
don't watch the news here let's see
what's going on here
are they still winning
ukraine
let's see here
here we go ukraine here we go
all right
russia ukraine war
ukraine rejects deadline to surrender
oh boy
in some city i don't want to disrespect
it
mariupol
as russia threatens to eliminate
resistance
uh they still haven't surrendered pm
says at least five dead 20 injured
uh
senators heading to poland india germany
to rally ukraine support
all right well they're hanging tough
they're hanging tough i don't know i
would have thought
i don't know
i would've thought russia big bad russia
with all those weapons and [ __ ] i would
have thought this would have been you
know
an easy win for him and look at him
they're in a damn dog fight here
um why am i talking about this like it's
a [ __ ] game you know why because it's
depressing it's beyond [ __ ]
depressing and then also
seeing all of this horrible [ __ ]
done to the ukrainian people and knowing
what the [ __ ] my country's been doing
for 20 years even though they don't show
it over here the whole thing is just
[ __ ] depressing that's what it is
okay there you got it all right let's
look up uh
let's look up uh what have i got and not
look up let me let me do the reads here
for the week all right oh look who it is
everybody roman
you know when the i almost just threw up
my back saying that that's how old i am
oh okay roman
when the when though i [ __ ] up my back
you got to be kidding me i had my legs
to the side i took a big inhale and i
yelled roman ah i think i got a lawsuit
here all right roman when the moment for
intimacy arrives
you need to be ready roman ready whether
you've been in a relationship for years
or just getting started having the
confidence that comes from preparation
means you're free to enjoy the moment
when the moment comes
even though you're far from ordinary
you're special the truth is
that erectile dysfunction
is really common in fact 52 percent of
guys age 40 to 70 experience some form
of
erectile dysfunction
but it happens to guys that's why you
never hear about it at the oscars uh
go to getroman.com
now to speak to a u.s licensed health
care professional about erectile
dysfunction and get 15 off your first
month of treatment e.d is more common
than most people think in fact 52
percent of meant we just said this uh
roman ready is confidence personified it
is the self-insurance that comes that
knowing when you turn the key it's going
to start right up roman's system is
completely confidential and totally
discreet no big logos or labels or
packages it'd be funny if their logo you
know like the the nba logo
the silhouette of that white dude right
what if this did it was just a [ __ ]
flaccid dick
turning into a rager
right like like uh the evolution of man
uh with roman you can get a free online
evaluation ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your own home a u.s licensed
healthcare professional will work with
you uh to find the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate it ships to
you free with two day shipping the whole
process is straightforward convenient
and discreet get started getting started
is simple just go to
getromand.com and complete an online
visit take care of your ed without
leaving your home complete an online
visit today to connect with the u.s
licensed healthcare professional and
take care of it go to getroman.com
b-u-r-r today and if you're prescribed
get 15 off your first month of erectile
dysfunction dysfunction treatment make
sure you're ready to have confidence and
control this fall roman ready
um fix your dick
at romanready.com is that what it is at
getroman.com something like that all
right policy genius everybody
hey man
typically life insurance gets more
expensive as you age
so it's smart to get a policy sooner
rather than later policy genius is your
one-stop shop to find the insurance you
need at the right price click the link
in the description or head to
policygenius.com and answer a few
questions in minutes you can compare
personalized quotes from top companies
to find your lowest price you could save
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius the
team of the team of licensed experts at
policy genius are on hand through the
entire process to help you understand
your options and make decisions with
confidence the policy genius team works
for you not the insurance company
whether you're just starting to shop or
you have questions about your active
policy uh that you're independent
independent advocates offering unbiased
advice policy genius doesn't sell your
info to third parties well there's a
rarity uh head to policygenius.com to
get your free insurance quotes and see
how much you could save
all right who else we got here oh look
who it is last but not least bespoke
post
you know this spring revamp your daily
routine with bespoke post and their new
seasonal lineup of must-have
box of awesome collections bespoke i
could use this i've not bought clothes
since before the pandemic but bespoke
post partners with small businesses and
emerging brands to bring you the most
unique goods every month my friend paul
got a machete that's right paul verse he
got a [ __ ] machete uh no matter what
you're going
uh what you have going on this season
box of awesome has you covered from
camping gear essentials to cookout out
must-haves like hot sauces and bbq rubs
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories each box is valued
at around seventy dollars but you only
pay a fraction of that price plus with
each box of awesome you're supporting
small businesses
uh a small business uh ninety percent of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up and coming
brand it's free free to sign up you can
skip a month or cancel any time get 20
off your first box monthly box when you
sign up at box of boss dot com and enter
the code burr at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code bur for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com code burr
that was a mouthful
all right well there you go
yeah
my buddy versy got a machete
a [ __ ] machete
what is the purpose of a machete
if you don't live near a jungle it's
like you want to [ __ ] kill somebody
um
or scare the [ __ ] out of them
that is the knife version of a [ __ ]
shotgun
right
taking a machete out of its sheath that
sound you know they say if you just get
a shotgun you go
you know the the you know in theory the
guy the intruder hears it
and [ __ ] runs away
that's what they say that's what they
say happens my thing is if what if you
what if you go
and then you hear
oh [ __ ]
i'm out gunned
there's the next sound you make the
sound of you laying your shotgun on the
floor i have no idea and i know a
machete is not a knife
that's not a knife this is a knife a
machete oh crocodile dundee huh 40 years
later still quoting it
um
i know it's is it a sword
let me let's look this up
machete it's a great [ __ ] band i do
know that
is it a band
or is it a movie i think it's a movie
a machete
knife
or sort i think the just the fact that
i'm gonna i'm gonna look this up
is gonna make them dumb down all of my
advertising
long story short all machetes are knives
not all knives are machetes
what makes a sword a sword the instant
when a machete is wielded like a weapon
it might be seen as a sword
all right is a machete a knife or a
sword see this is what you come to this
podcast for
all right for some of us they are best
known as cutlasses or corn pickers
who the [ __ ] calls it a cutlass
since the 1500s maybe if you live back
then
um you might have
other local names for this diverse tool
looking at one though is a machete a
knife for some kind of sword or
something else machetes are considered
bigger knives due to their build purpose
and construction
the tang of the machete is shorter than
the swords
and closer to that of a knife the [ __ ]
is a tang
fitted with a thinner edge compared to
most cutting tools they are best placed
in a large larger knife category instead
all right let's look up tang
it's a drink from where i'm from what is
the tang
of a knife
tang refers to the part of the knife
blade that extends to the handle
everything extends to the handle
depends the way you start looking
the tang plays an important factor in
products cost as well as how a knife
performs with constant use a knife can
either be full tang or partial tang
i mean i don't
does it matter if my kitchen knife is
full tang now this just has to be cooks
what is a full tang
what is knife tank tang refers to the
part of knight extends into the handle
okay so it's not the blade part the
other part
tank plays an important knife can be
full full tang a full tang knife blade
extends fully
through the handle
both in length and width
oh i see it disappears into the handle
and they just have a little skinny
thing there they're gonna learn a whole
bunch of [ __ ] about knives
all
right are considered big knives due to
their build and construction the tang of
the machete is shorter than that of a
sword
ah closer to that of a knife
so the metal part that goes into the
handle is shorter on a machete
i don't know
i i just i would rather face somebody
that has a sword than a machete
because i feel like you know if you have
a sword
you know you're a little light in the
loafers right if you have a machete
you're a [ __ ] lunatic
[Music]
you know all the things i didn't think
i'd be talking about on this podcast it
would have been that
on god i feel like that's a that's a
sword guy on guard
and i feel like a machete guy you
[ __ ]
it's just some angry dad
who just ran through a screen door to
catch you before your el camino pulls
away um
all right
we do have some reads here for the week
oh you know what i did i am not allowed
to fly
for another like nine weeks i had to get
through the shoot and then in 10 weeks i
owe my first cut and at that point i can
fly
so you know like any engine i got to
keep it running so i i
you know
i just
tow it out with the four-wheeler and
then i let it run for 20 minutes
you know a couple times a week and uh
i was to the point now i needed fuel so
i actually went and i gassed it up and
it actually just made me feel like a
pilot again
just doing that
you know
but you know what i do when i just sit
there for 20 [ __ ] minutes
just resisting the urge
huh
to start raising that collective as i
push my right foot in
push my right foot down
coming straight up
and flying off into the blue blue yonder
you know what i do is i i
for the pilots out there i just load
like approaches so i don't forget how to
do that
you know i just mess with my garmin
you know [ __ ]
discovering all types of stuff that it
has
that i didn't know how to do because i
was so busy learning how to
fly this one
um
but i ca oh my god i'm going out of my
[ __ ] mind with that
i just love i love the smell of the fuel
i i just love the way the helicopter
looks
i there's nothing just that feeling
you know
my favorite thing too is when i'm done
with the flight coming in
and just setting it right down on the
pad when there's people watching
before i used to get kind of the yips
and i go down and go up and go down and
go up and then back up and then have to
do it again
and then by then people are filming like
is he going to crash it
because that's what they want um which
by the way you know why you would if you
you'd film somebody doing that
if you thought that that was gonna be
the result
why you would film someone that [ __ ]
close
with the main rotor spinning like that
and the shrapnel that's gonna come your
[ __ ] way
like i gotta be honest with you like one
of the dumbest things you could ever
[ __ ] do as far as risking your life
is going to a [ __ ] air show
you're out of your mind
every one time i went to go see the blue
angels when i was a kid
and just thinking like these guys like
went
just peeled off in two different
directions and then flew right at each
other like like a game of chicken and at
the last second they both
turned on their side
you know
like [ __ ] 90 degrees
so their wings were completely pointed
north south
they both turned the opposite way and
just missed each other and they passed
each other like right in front of us
[ __ ] insane
it's amazing how like you know when when
you're expecting to see something how
much you'll put your guard down
you know
like when you see a lion at the zoo
if you can you got your head hanging
over the side
because you're expecting to see a
[ __ ] light it's the only time you
ever walk towards a tiger or a gorilla
or any of that [ __ ] is when you're at
the zoo and like the [ __ ] air shows
the same thing if there was two planes
flying at each other
[ __ ] around i mean what are you doing
besides running for cover instead of
sitting there
right where the place of impact is going
to be you [ __ ] run
so i've had you know since i gotten
gotten dude since i've gotten
since i got my pilot's license i've had
a number of people ask me
if i wanted to go to an air show and i
was i'm always just like
can i just watch it on youtube it's it's
[ __ ] awesome i love
like the level of pilot there is insane
but the level of risk
is ridiculous
i feel like to just sit there and just
watch people
doing [ __ ] like that
um
i don't know
whatever the older you get the more i
don't know the smarter you get the more
fearful you get where you're kind of
like you know what i think i think i'm
all right on that i think i'm all right
on that um
all right whatever the bottom line we
learned the difference that a a machete
because of its tang
is in the knife
family
right
i mean dude that is something all you
guys you got to keep that
you got to keep that and just hope one
day
you're at a party
and somehow the topic of a machete comes
up and somebody goes is a machete a
sword or a knife
and then you can just be like it's a
knife
why is it a knife uh because of the size
of its tang
and then you then immediately you just
walk out of the room
i mean i would almost hire somebody to
say that to me in front of other people
i want to impress at this point
because of its tang
um
okay uh
i don't know if i'm saying something in
a different language or this is a a a uh
oh this is a city
equal louis
hello bill
you said you are looking to play unique
places
as you believe you played them all well
we are in the arctic
and we would love to have you
equality is the capital city of nunavut
and we have about 9 000 people our venue
holds 500 people i know you play to
arenas and such but i thought it could
be a unique opportunity where are you
where is this place
none of what
none of us
[Music]
oh it's in canada
oh
these are the ogs
the original peoples
you know you know canada likes to act
like they're the better white people
um yeah there was people there before
they got there and then they they moved
them all the way up there i would
[ __ ] play this didn't jack white play
up there
hang on a second
where is it at
i would play there i absolutely would
play there
abso [ __ ] lutely now wait a minute
now where's the capitol
you got me interested god damn it
jesus christ how many how many [ __ ]
planes do i gotta take to get to there
dude i'll go there when the [ __ ]
northern lights are happening i'll bring
my lovely wife let's do it
let's [ __ ] do it all right you know
what
i'm going to try to make that happen
now that i'm saying it i'm going to text
my age text my agent right [ __ ] now
who has an agent oh mr [ __ ] hollywood
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
all right i can't do that because i'm
afraid it's going to shut the recorder
off um
this is not a high-tech i'm getting my
my high-tech i got a green i'm looking
at a green screen right now meaning a
green piece of cloth
behind my screen in my office it's all
going down slowly
um all right macon hey billy beef
bulgogi burr i don't know what that
means i just wanted to say i came and
saw you in macon and you crushed it man
i can't tell you what a [ __ ]
blast i had there and to also know that
that was the home base of the allman
brothers which was the favorite band of
the late great david richardson who some
of the biggest laughs on efforts for
family he wrote
and forget about the ones that we
couldn't put in the show one of the
funniest guys i ever met
um
and he said such a great laugh um so
maybe that's another reason why i just
connected to that place
um it was my first time ever going to
any comedy show and it was a great time
it was also my first time watching paul
verzi
and he killed as well and now
and i'm now a fan of him but while he
was on stage doing his set i was sitting
perfectly so the stage light were
hitting his watch and the reflection
would hit me in the face he would love
that he would
i immediately remembered how you said on
the podcast that verzi is sicilian and
they like their shiny things and i
started dying laughing yeah i'm telling
you
like
being friends with paul verzi
he's also the reason i'm married he
talked me off the ledge
he's like dude where you going you got
her you got the woman you're not going
anywhere he goes i'm telling you all you
got to do is just get through
the vows and then it's like the greatest
party ever with all your best friends
um
but also he
introduced me to a subset
of people that i didn't even understand
sneakerheads and all of that [ __ ] i
guess i would have seen some of that on
the news
you know when somebody gets shot over a
pair of [ __ ] i don't know easter
shelters limited editions
um
yeah all of that [ __ ] the the jewelry
the [ __ ] chains uh which is jewelry
the [ __ ] sneakers all of that [ __ ]
don't crease your sneakers and [ __ ]
i i it's just fascinating to me
um anyway he goes i guess that's oh i
[ __ ] up his joke he said i immediately
remembered how you said on the podcast
of that version is sicilian and they
like their shiny things and i started
dying laughing i guess that's why he
likes you and your shiny bald head oh
look at that a first [ __ ]
bald joke of easter weekend um if you
come back to macon you need to go to my
hometown which is about 20 minutes south
and go to the museum of aviation
i would definitely do that it's a free
museum by the air force base in my
hometown and it has old warplanes and
helicopters there you go you can see and
actually sit in some of the cockpits i'm
sure you would love to visit and i'll
put a link for you if you are interested
thanks for the laughs and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah i gotta tell you i don't
know what it was about macon but
i connected to that place and that
venue um
the way i i have that's crazy in some of
those southern
states they just have these these venues
i don't know what it is you walk in you
feel the history of them and i don't
know
um jesus christ what's the name of that
place in atlanta i did a special day i
haven't been there in a while
i'd love to go back was it the
tabernacle
all right the tabernacle
yeah that place
um
that place in macon i just went to i
went to a place in like uh
i want to say south carolina along the
coast
super old
venue
i don't know
well i'm glad you came down then you
sound like a funny bastard yourself
um all right american-made turntables
wait a second i'm asking people to write
in that make some american-made stuff so
i can give a shout out
to their businesses business this is
here american-made turntables
hey
billow
bill or willem oh billa willem
it was bola willam bola willem bull
hey bulla
uh i'm writing to you from the greater
boston area and i work for a company
that makes turntables and speakers
called u-turn audio
link at the bottom u-turn like like
the letter u dash turn audio they are
based just north of the city and all
their products are manufactured in the
united states this is so great to know
the company has been around since the
early 2010s and i've been working there
since 2020. it was founded by three
friends who all grew up together and
over the years have strived to put out
quality products at an affordable price
i am i know i'm
the past i know in the past you've
you've
wait i know i'm the past you've takes
about
already owning i okay i know in the past
you've talked about already owning a
record player but if you want another
one consider u-turn comedian mark maron
and ac dc bases cliff williams both own
one if you want to gauge our clientele
what you know what my mother-in-law
needs one i'm going to get her one all
the best to you and your family go [ __ ]
yourself i'm all over that
i'm going to be in boston this week
everybody
i'm going to be in boston this week
oh i forgot to tell you
i'm doing a i'm doing a show
august 21st
in boston massachusetts at fenway park
yes fenway park first time they've ever
had stand-up comedy there
it's gonna be me and the great tony v
and uh
and to promote it they're having me
throw out the first pitch
on tuesday
we'll see how that goes you know what's
funny people are going like dude
whatever you do you can't bounce it
are you gonna throw from the rubber you
can't i love you can't bounce it why
can't i bounce it i'm a 53 year old
comedian i can throw it over the [ __ ]
backstop if i want to i'm not getting
paid to do this [ __ ] i'm telling you
right now i'm going out to the rubber
and i'm i'm i'm gonna bring some
53-year-old never picked in gym class
gas we'll see how it goes
and you know what i'm gonna try to see
if i got some time to go up to u-turn
audio i would love to do that get my uh
well you know i'll click on the [ __ ]
website i can make it easier on myself
right
u-turn audio
now that is a sexy ass turntable would
you look at that
would you look at that
oh they got all the different colors all
right i'm sold i'm getting one i'm
getting what
going through puberty here yeah i am uh
beyond excited
um i wasn't allowed to bring this up but
i know today we're announcing it i got
to make sure that we're announcing it
out to cut this part of the podcast out
um
yeah
let's just say
that i i will definitely be burning the
light that night
okay
whatever time they tell me i have to do
i'm doing more than that
this is gonna be absolutely
[ __ ]
epic
i can't believe this is happening every
time i i i i can't even think about it i
am so [ __ ] excited for it i am like
literally this morning i was making
my beautiful kids pancakes and i was
like bits were coming together in my
head
and i was writing them down and my kids
are going dad what's with the pancakes
i'm like hang on a second
i'm writing something about the who was
no um i didn't say that
um
dad i could tell he wasn't the easter
bunny because he was wearing shoes
i mean what do you say to that i almost
spilled all the beans
that was like the smoking gun i almost
said all right
there's no santa claus either there's no
[ __ ] tooth fairy
you know there's no gold behind our
currency
you know jesus existed but whether or
not he was a prophet i don't even think
he was white you know
i don't know what he was the man had
pigment though i can tell you that and
you know if you listen to nas i'm sure
he'll say he's from africa but then
other people say we're all from africa
and then neil degrasse tyson said we
came from the tree some or the water or
some [ __ ] i don't you know what i don't
know anything
okay
other than that i love you there you go
how's that a good way to say there's no
santa claus all right overrated
underrated
underrated easter
people tend to overlook this holiday but
i can't think of a lower rent slash
higher luxury than easter i don't need
to buy gifts
i'm old enough to blow off church i get
a huge meal out of it and the weather is
getting nicer people enjoy it way more
than they know
unless they're jewish and they're like
oh jesus
shout out to other religions doing their
thing this time of year
almost like they all came from the same
uh ancient tales oh jesus yeah we're all
this [ __ ] same as stupid
um overrated tired opinions oh god i
feel like i'm going to get heckled on
this one
uh
tired of opinions dear billy no bed head
oh
oh that one's just sad
uh i'm tired of people who don't
understand something spout off
opinions they heard
uh ringo is a bad drummer is one of them
yeah that's something you'll never hear
from a [ __ ]
a professional musician who ever had to
go into a recording studio and play for
a song
another one is people in blank are blank
as if everyone is a particular place
is all the same when it comes to manners
or demeanor
uh do you have any hate
it might take just another tired opinion
and i'm guilty too
okay you were doing great to that last
sentence it might it might take i think
you mean it's just my take just another
tired opinion am i guilty too that's
what you're trying to say that was
actually really well written
that you brought it back around we're
all guilty of that i trashed all toronto
blue jay fans because of getty lee
you know and all he was doing was being
funny the guy was being a sports fan he
was at a blue jays game and they were
playing the the red sox so
some red sox fans were there they were
probably making noise in his stadium so
he's [ __ ] on him like he's supposed to
and what did i do i attacked him his
band
the entire providence
province not providence that's in rhode
island province
of toronto
um all right well this is a great
podcast i have a new place where i'm
gonna go do a gig
um
whenever the northern lights are
i'm gonna head up there and then uh
to
equilite
none of it um
you'll have none of it none of us
um
and i got a turntable i'm gonna get for
my
my uh my mother-in-law
beautiful
isn't that wonderful you know what i'm
gonna do tonight you know what i'm gonna
do tonight because i got a bunch of
shows coming up i'm gonna be in
pittsburgh columbus cleveland all of
these places guess what i'm doing i'm
going out of the comedy club all right
i'm putting on my sweatpants and my
headband my [ __ ] leg warmers and i'm
gonna go around there i'm gonna run my
[ __ ] hour and all my new jokes
because i got a
big week of shows and i got the biggest
show of my [ __ ] life coming up august
21st at fenway park i cannot believe it
30 years ago
oh billy freckles no beard
full head of thick
i had a lion's mane a [ __ ]
gorgeous
[ __ ]
the red waves
were [ __ ] happening right
stepped on stage at nick's comedy stop i
knew i wanted to to get somewhere in
this business i never thought in a
zillion years it would lead to pla to
doing stand-up at a baseball park no
forget about that one
where i have i think i'll spend the
whole [ __ ] time up there just telling
stories about being hammered in that
that
stadium park i guess park you call it um
oh my god
yeah that's a big one that is a big one
so anyways old freckles throwing the
first pitch out he's coming from the
rubber
that's it coming from the rubber and i'm
gonna i'm gonna uh we'll see how i do
but i'm not putting any pressure on
myself because at the end of the day i'm
a comedian if i bounce it it's supposed
to be funny and no matter what i do it
could never be worse than what 50 cent
did
you know
or could it
we shall find out um all right what else
what else
got a few more minutes to kill here is
there anything else i got coming up
let's talk about some of my let's see
what the dates i don't even know where
i'm gonna be
i'm just gonna get past this [ __ ]
first pitch thing
uh
let's see googling yourself
[ __ ] ego move
all right
tickets okay where am i gonna be
where am i gonna be all right
this is this new thing they do they they
show you tickets where you're living
okay
thursday
thursday i'm gonna be in pittsburgh
pennsylvania
um one of the most underrated cities
um
in the united states and i do not
understand why
hey if you're from europe and you want
to go somewhere different go to
pittsburgh
the only thing that sucks about
pittsburgh is the owner of the the
owners of the pirates if they could just
just let that team go
give it to someone who wants to win that
would be fantastic
um
oh my god then i'm in nashville
tennessee
that shows this week [ __ ]
that's a big one too then i'm at denim
in cleveland and then i'm in columbus
holy summoning [ __ ]
um
yeah i got some big ones coming up
i got some big ones coming up holy [ __ ]
all right i gotta make sure that all
yeah i gotta go do my act all right i
gotta
i gotta
[ __ ] i gotta i gotta go do some stand up
all right that's it
that's the podcast
for uh for this this week here
have a great couple of days go [ __ ]
yourself and i'll check in on you
on thursday